Nos dicen que el paralelogramo ABCD tiene los
siguientes vértices, y nos dan las coordenadas
de los diferentes vértices, y nos preguntan: "¿El
paralelogramo ABCD es un rectángulo?, ¿por qué?"
Pausa el video y trata de pensar en esto por tu
cuenta antes de que trabajemos juntos. Muy bien,
ahora trabajemos juntos. En general, si sabemos
que tenemos un paralelogramo y queremos determinar
si es un rectángulo, en realidad es cuestión de
saber si los lados adyacentes se intersecan en un
ángulo recto. Por ejemplo, un paralelogramo podría
verse así. Lo que sabemos sobre un paralelogramo
es que los lados opuestos son paralelos, de modo
que este lado es paralelo a este lado y este lado
es paralelo a este lado. Todos los rectángulos son
paralelogramos pero no todos los paralelogramos
son rectángulos. Para que un paralelogramo sea
un rectángulo, estos lados deben intersecarse en
ángulos rectos; y claramente por la forma en
que dibujé este paralelogramo eso no es así.
Pero veamos si podemos resolver esto con base en
las coordenadas que nos han dado, y para ayudarnos
a visualizarlo déjenme poner algunas coordenadas.
Vamos a dibujar los ejes, así que este es el eje
X y este es el eje Y. Veamos las coordenadas:
tenemos 2, 4, 6 y 8, entonces tenemos 2, 4, 6 y 8,
y luego tenemos -2, -4, -6 y -8, tenemos 2, 4, 6
y 8 y luego tenemos -2, -4, -6 y -8. Cada marca
corresponde a 2 -estoy contando de dos en dos-.
Tracemos estos puntos y lo haremos en un color
diferente para que los veamos mejor. A está en -6,
-4, entonces tenemos -2, -4, -6 y luego -4 está
por aquí, este es el punto A. Luego tenemos el
punto B en -2,6, entonces -2 y 2, 4, 6, el punto B
está justo aquí. Luego tenemos el punto C en 8,2,
8,2, justo aquí este es el punto C. Y por último,
pero no menos importante, tenemos el punto D en
4,-8 justo aquí tenemos el punto D. De modo que
nuestro cuadrilátero -en realidad sabemos que es
un paralelogramo- se ve así. Tenemos un segmento
AB que se ve así, un segmento BC que se ve así, el
segmento CD y el segmento AD se ve así. Ya sabemos
que es un paralelogramo, de modo que sabemos que
el segmento AB es paralelo al segmento BC y el
segmento BC es paralelo al segmento AB, pero lo
que realmente necesitamos hacer es descubrir si se
intersecan en ángulos rectos. Tenemos que calcular
las pendientes de estos segmentos de recta usando
las coordenadas. Calculemos primero la pendiente
de AB. La pendiente del segmento AB va a ser igual
al cambio en Y sobre el cambio en X, entonces
nuestro cambio en Y será igual a 6 menos -4,
6 - - 4, sobre -2 - -6, -2 - -6, esto es igual a 6
+ 4, que es igual a 10 / -2 - -6, que es lo mismo
que 2 + 6, esto es igual a 4, que es lo mismo
que 5/2. Muy bien, esto es interesante. ¿Cuál
es la pendiente del segmento BC? La pendiente
del segmento BC es igual al cambio en Y sobre el
cambio en X, el cambio de nuestras coordenadas del
eje Y es igual a 2 - 6, 2 - 6 / 8 - -2, 8 - -2,
que es igual a -4 / 8 - -2, es lo mismo que 8 +
2, que es igual a 10, y esto es lo mismo que -2/5.
Ahora, en otros videos de la clase de álgebra es
posible que hayas aprendido que las pendientes de
las rectas que se intersecan en ángulo recto,
las pendientes de las rectas que forman un
ángulo recto en su punto de intersección, van
a ser los recíprocos opuestos, y en realidad
es lo que podemos ver aquí, estos son recíprocos
opuestos. Si tomamos el recíproco de la pendiente
que tenemos aquí arriba, obtenemos 2/5 y luego
tomamos el opuesto, o en este caso el negativo,
vamos a tener -2/5, de modo que estas son rectas
perpendiculares. Esto nos permite saber que el
segmento AB es perpendicular al segmento BC,
entonces sabemos que este es el caso. Y podríamos
seguir haciendo esto, pero en un paralelogramo,
si un conjunto de segmentos se intersecan en un
ángulo recto, todos ellos se intersecan en ángulos
rectos. Podríamos demostrarlo más rigurosamente,
pero esto es suficiente evidencia para mí.
Esto es un rectángulo. Si lo desean pueden
continuar haciendo este análisis y comprobar que
esto es perpendicular, esto es perpendicular y
esto también es perpendicular. Pero veamos
cuál de estas opciones coincide con lo que
acabamos de deducir. La opción A dice que sí, y
sí se refiere a que es un rectángulo porque la
longitud del segmento AB es igual a la longitud
del segmento AB y la longitud del segmento BC
es igual a la longitud del segmento CD. Eso podría
ser cierto, no lo hemos validado, pero sólo porque
esto sea cierto y porque sepamos que ABCD es
un paralelogramo eso no nos permite saber si
en realidad estamos tratando con un rectángulo.
Por ejemplo, podemos tener un paralelogramo donde
incluso todos los lados sean congruentes, entonces
podríamos tener un paralelogramo que se vea así;
y obviamente si todos los lados son congruentes
estamos tratando con un rombo, pero un rombo no
necesariamente va a ser un rectángulo, de modo
que descartamos esta opción. Esta segunda opción
dice que sí porque BC es perpendicular a AB. Sí,
vimos eso al comprobar que sus pendientes son
los recíprocos opuestos el uno del otro, y por
supuesto sabemos que ABCD es un paralelogramo,
así que me gusta esta opción. Y estas
opciones afirman que esto no es un rectángulo,
pero ya dedujimos que es un rectángulo, de
modo que podríamos descartar estas también.